I happen to be in the hangover I was in
it so I'm gonna look for you again
Stephen Brody Stephens host of Valley
vibes on all things comedy you've heard
of Valley vibes yeah it's a popular show
it's catching on
[Music]
we are here in Reseda California for
Valley vibes I'm your host Stephen Brody
Stephens
I chose receipt of me personally is
because I spent a lot of time I went to
Reseda high school hi everybody I'm
Stephen Brody Stevens welcome to Valley
vibes here on all things comedy this is
where I spent a lot of time
this is Reseda Reseda California a lot
of people would ask me Brody
when did Reseda become an official
incorporated city Reseda was formed in
1912 now this is a receipt a park sign
it's made of wood it has a rock
formations you got it thank you
Hollywood has it signed receipt oh right
there in official if you can go ahead
and get that that's an official sign of
Reseda receipt a park I believe is one
of the first public parks here in Los
Angeles to have lights how you guys
doing do you mind if we get a word for
you from you about the the park okay
thank you now the kids didn't want to
talk this is the lake wow this
is people go fishing in this lake
we have ducks we have geese
we have pigeons this beautiful
we have mallards we have the American
wigeon we have blue-winged teal we have
the American poop
come here goose I'm connecting with the
geese I'm connecting hi there feeding
the geese Canadian geese yes they come
from Canada they migrate recede a pride
that's the one thing that Reseda always
preached was Reseda pride have pride in
it because you know growing up as a kid
and you see stuff like oh you received
it you're from Reseda you could it can
affect your self-esteem or you can take
that with a chip on your shoulder or a
badge of honor and go yeah I'm from
Reseda what do you think about that we
go to concerts we take those we drive
you go to con you saw blondie where'd
you see her at Hollywood Bowl Hollywood
Bowl
remember the country club in Reseda
people don't realize on Sherman Way and
we'll go check that out the country club
world famous club now I think it's a
Mexican Church we're coming up here on
Sherman Way and we're going to check out
the donut shop featured in Boogie Nights
this is the spot in front of Miss Donuts
here where the world was introduced to
Don Cheadle Don Cheadle had a warmth
about him so when this scene took place
inside mrs. Donuts here on Sherman Way
in Reseda all of those factors played a
role in having sympathy for the
protagonist character so when the crime
took place Don Cheadle's character
you're saying hey
you're saying hey there might have been
a nest in here kind of a bird sanctuary
Reseda is very bird friendly driving
down West right now on Sherman Way we're
heading towards mr. Miyagi's bonsai room
daniel larusso's apartment he just moved
here Daniel I'm coming home
[Music]
[Applause]
well we're now here at the karate kid'
apartment the South Seas here in Reseda
this is where Daniel Larusso and mr.
Miyagi met now I have a bicycle here
when they said Brody we're gonna go do
the karate kid' apartment and I go I
will do it under one stipulation I said
get me the karate kid Daniel Larusso
bike and look what we got we got the
real deal
Mongoose forgive me if I get emotional I
mean this is Valley vibes it's not known
as a series that taps in to the
emotional side we're light we're polite
we're positive but I would be lying to
you if I said that I'm not getting a
sense of nostalgia thinking of my youth
thinking of my childhood thinking of my
times living in this neighborhood
this is where all the action happened
this used to be a chain-link fence it's
been replaced by a cinderblock wall I
expected to see an untouched scene
chain-link fence
cow pastures visualising zapka hopping
the fence going after Daniel Larusso
having mr. Miyagi pop out of the bonsai
room and fight off Zabka and his goons
but because of capitalism because of the
real estate market because of these
greedy millionaires it's gone my
childhood has been taken away from me
and that's something that I did not
anticipate when I signed up to do Valley
vibes
[Music]
hi everybody welcome to Valley vibes
with Stephen Brody Stephens all right so
we're going to Reseda high school now hi
everybody welcome back to Valley vibes
with Stephen Brody Stevens were here at
Reseda high school these are the kind of
guys who said yes I will be here so
we're here with our athletic director
but none to put on this Fernando
Fernandez yes sir
that'll be here he's excited to be here
and then we have our brand new head
baseball coach outfit of the month happy
to be here he's happy to be here that's
the attitude of Reseda
now this field is 310 I hit about 5 home
runs here during spring ball never like
an official game but I hit some bombs
over the fence oh yeah I hit I hit a car
one time I hit a Volvo
I hit home runs it gets like Franklin we
played Birmingham do you mind if I we
play a little catch just for old times
sake okay
I brought my glove
[Music]
basketball purple
Oh Great Lent thank you awesome awesome
I still got it awesome pitching fastball
curveball strikes curb uh still bites
and I'll tell you what Reseda is a good
school you got men to like this men like
these guys leading the way I like it I
want to see more we're gonna go to the
basketball arena is it the basketball
arena or the gym it's basically the gym
okay basketball gym is that filtered yes
it is that's good water
I spent a lot of time on this football
field I think I'm just gonna cruise
around a little bit
check out the campus it's a Saturday so
it's cool and I want to say thanks guys
for coming out I appreciate it this is I
could go on all day my question is this
yeah up there
exactly how come there's not a baseball
player that needs to be addressed and
needs to be changed
and today is the day once a regent
always a region so thanks again guys I
appreciate it awesome and I and I and I
look forward to coming out this year you
saw I still got it so that brings to the
end that brings us to the end of this
episode of Valley vibes with Stephen
Brody Stephens here in Reseda as we talk
about baseball coaching we talked about
feeding your local birds we saw the
Karate Kid apartment I took you to the
doughnut shop where Don Cheadle was
discovered I don't know what other
programs will
you those nuggets of information this is
Valley vibes with Stephen Brody Stephens
yes
I'm Stephen Brody Stephens from Valley
vibes hello